in november last year after a highly
publicized legal battle britney spears
was freed from a brutal 13-year long
conservatorship to put her father in
charge of her finances her healthcare
and her personal decisions effectively
her entire life well since then she
celebrated her freedom by posting
pictures to her 41 million followers on
instagram naked pictures well last week
alone she's posted a series of them
concerned fans have flocked to social
media as they always love to do is
brittany okay is she having another
mental breakdown
well i don't think she is i wrote a
column for the sun this week saying
actually i think she's expressing the
freedom she didn't have for all those
years of that conservatorship which
became incredibly draconian but to
discuss all this i'm joined by music
management legend louis walsh his words
not mine he'll actually walk with
brittany as a judge on x factor usa in
2012 and fox nation host tommy lehrer
who's an unashamed britney fan well
let's start with you tommy um you know i
looked at these pictures i've got to say
my first reaction was to be a bit
concerned about what she doing because
she's got a history of erratic behavior
but actually when i read the captions
and i saw what she was sort of saying
about it i genuinely felt this is a
woman who feels liberated she always
talked about the time of the
conservatorship as being like being in
prison what do you think
i'm free britney all the way she's
living her life she's loving her life
and you know what piers what celebrity
doesn't post nude photos or suggestive
photos i mean scroll through and pick a
name any name pick a kardashian any
kardashian they're all part of this kind
of stuff is
is it a little bizarre sure it's a
little bizarre but with all the
craziness that goes on in hollywood and
in the media with public figures let
brittany be britney she's not hurting
anybody she's enjoying her freedom and
let her freak flag fly if she so chooses
it's all up to her thank goodness she is
finally free yeah i kind of feel that
louis you've got a history with britney
because you did judge x factor usa with
her and it was a bit of a nightmare
wasn't it she she did one show of thing
and over two days
was sort of completely out of it a bit
of a diva about everything and you were
worried and maybe
yeah
tell me about it she wasn't in a good
place she wasn't in a good place but you
know i'm a fan as well appears and she's
a complete survivor she's 40 years old
she can do whatever she wants madonna's
taking her all her clothes off all the
time why can't britney do it you know
and i just think
she's enjoying her life you know and
she's free but i'd like her to make a
record i'd like her to have a hit song
get back in studio with mix martin or
somebody because i i remember
i remember watching her perform on the x
factor uk
two or three years before you judged it
i think 2008 nine something like that
and it was a really shocking performance
and she was only about 27. i thought
this is the beginning of the end you
know it's really all over four yeah i
remember but when i look at it now
yeah i want to look at it now though
louis i think yeah i think you know one
great song
and it could be one of the all-time
great comebacks right
totally max martin brittany you get a
hit absolutely and she is a great pop
star she's a household name she's got
really loyal fans you know and she can
do what she wants so who's taking the
pictures by the way it's not her so it
must be her guy
well i mean she's been with this guy
tommy for five years she's pregnant
expecting another baby um let me just
ask you that even as a sort of super fan
uh does any part of any of this worry
you a little bit in the sense that
when someone does get liberated after so
long
under someone's control like a father
you know it can it can go wrong are you
worried it might or do you trust the
process here
i think that you know obviously the
posts are a little weird i'm not gonna
lie to you i'm a britney fan i look at
them and you know i cringe from time to
time but like i said what celebrity
isn't posting weird stuff what celebrity
isn't erratic we've got so many other
celebrities and pop stars and figures
changing their gender from one day to
the next let brittany do what she wants
to do she was miserable under that
conservatorship she said she was
miserable she was acute enough to
understand she was miserable in that
conservatorship so you know what if
she's happy now that's all that matters
of course we hope that the family and
friends that she's still close to we
hope that they're watching over her we
want the best for brittany but i think
she's going to make a huge comeback i
think she's going to be stronger than
ever and she's going to do it on her
terms i just realized you actually look
a bit like britney
yeah
hey i take that as a major compliment
i intended it as a compliment uh louis
i've got to ask you before i let you go
simon cowell is is on the verge of a
truly historic moment where it looks
like he may actually get he may actually
get married do you believe it's going to
happen what's your thought about this i
don't know pierce you know as much as i
do you know he loves himself more than
anybody else you know so lauren is
hanging in
a long time maybe he should get married
i don't know he told me he never would
so i don't know he's engaged lauren
deserves it she's hung around a long
time she deserves it she's a lovely lady
laura she's a lovely lady
i've got a feeling he is actually gonna
finally crumble
do you think so
i think so yeah
are you gonna go i don't know i mean
he's so tight isn't he would you invite
anyone to come and drink at his expense
we'd have to see
we'd have to go we'll have to go even if
we're not invited we should actually be
best men me and you after all we've done
for him in the last 30 years we should
all we could be wiggling crashes
we could be wedding crashes if he's too
mean to invite us tommy i want to take
you back we let you go tommy uh you
talked about every celebrity who has
naked pictures on social media i don't
know if you were familiar with my own
work in this genre so here's my famous
burger king commercial um oh which was
me in a in a
burt reynolds loincloth by a roaring
half fire
and if you believe that's my real body
you're living in cloud cuckoo land but
anyway but you're right tommy we've all
done it uh to leave it there great
debate i'm glad to see brittany back i
think she's uh one of the all-time great
pop stars take care both of you tommy we
appreciate it